during this extended mad dash for buying
the perfect gift for that love one this
holiday ask yourself this question are
you buying a gift for someone that
reflects your core values
i always say you can pass on your
valuables to the next generation but you
should also pass on your values sherry
greco-riches is the founder of
rapaporricus capital management as a
financial advisor she says in order to
maximize your return on life spend your
time and money on what you value most i
kind of think of having your list of
core values is kind of your guide for
life your guide for your time and money
and then you can make decisions based on
your values as opposed to just decisions
in a vacuum gift giving doesn't have to
be tangible you can pass on your values
through a gift like a donation to
charity time together with an experience
enjoy something cultural together head
to the opera or ballet even a
sentimental gift like a photo album with
stories is very touching make a list of
everyone that you want to give a gift to
and put a dollar amount and try to stick
at it make sure you've got the basics
covered as well when it comes to
budgeting for the holiday
and then the step that sometimes doesn't
get taken is once you buy the gifts
start tracking so
all sudden you budgeted fifty dollars
for one family member and you found
something for sixty well maybe you know
you gotta reduce unfortunately another
family member
gotta make the math work now she says if
you're thinking of gifting bonds you may
as well give cash stocks are nice she
says for the sentimental reason like a
minor savings for grandkids that they
can use later on in life let's say a
down payment for a first car she says as
far as crypto it's a bit volatile so it
could be a gift that keeps on giving or
not be wary of that